[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler xavier
moreau fondateur de strates vol en
direct avec nous bonsoir xavier moreau
sur ce plateau régis le sommier grand
reporter arte france ainsi que le
général dominique trinquant expert en
géostratégie bonsoir à tous les deux
également beaucoup parlent ce soir
d'apaisement olaf scholz le premier qui
affirme qu'il ya suffisamment de base de
discussion avec la russie pour déboucher
sur des solutions positives
régis le sommier on se demande
concrètement qu'est ce qui a changé
aujourd'hui
puisque finalement vladimir poutine ne
cesse de répéter la même chose depuis le
début ce qui a changé c'est la faim fait
c'est le calendrier qui était militaire
qui a été établi comme ça la fin des
commandes et exercices des manoeuvres
entre l'armée russe ses larmes et bien
russes qui se sont déroulés
effectivement dans une zone proche de la
frontière pour une part et qu'une partie
de ses troupes allaient regagner ses
casernes en début de matinée et là on a
senti que effectivement il y avait une
forme d'apaisement ou en tout cas il y
avait quelque chose d'un point de vue
militaire qui pouvait changer la donne
c'est ce temps là les calendriers
famille au stade où on en met deux de
l'exacerbation de cette crise chaque
mouvement de soldats et regarder scruté
à la loupe les deux protagonistes dans
cette histoire voyant ce que les uns et
les autres font et évidemment
interprétant et voilà et ensuite si vous
avez toute la planète médiatique pour
interpréter ça donc ça c'est des signes
ensuite après vous avez cette visite en
effet du chancelier allemand qui est
n'est pas finalement fondamentalement
différente de du message qui en est qui
étaient ressortis de de la visite des
manuels macron quand on voit il ya
l'idée toujours d'essayer de te
rechercher des solutions que la crise
est complexe que voilà on ne va pas
avoir un accord comme ça dans l'immédiat
d'un point de vue russe il ya eu aussi
l'idée faut regarder les choses de ne
pas appuyer sur le détonateur c'est à
dire de ne pas reconnaître immédiatement
ou en tout cas procéder à ce qui était
demandé à la douma de reconnaître les
république autonome de l'est donc ça
c'est déjà une chose donc on est quand
même dans une situation où aujourd'hui
en deux en dehors je dirais de la presse
anglo saxonne on est quittes continuelle
comment l'arrêter de d'aller sur un
espèce de pouce à la guerre comme on a
déjà vu par le passé 1 c'est exactement
la même le même scénario que pendant la
guerre en irak ou d'autres guerres ou
tout à coup les journalistes américains
c'est à coup c'est je dirais open bar
c'est à dire qu'on peut raconter relayée
j'ai vu des confrères très honorable au
demeurant dans leur travail
journalistique relayer comme ça sans
filtre des vidéos de propagande de
l'armée ukrainienne finalement d'après
lui journalistique ça me choque je
souhaiterais que ce soit mise en
contexte et qu'on ne fasse pas de dire
voilà tout à coup comme si c'était un
jeu de société c'est la guerre quand
même voilà on va en parler effectivement
du rôle de ces médias général traquant
une partie des cent mille hommes
déployés autour de l'ukraine donc sont
retournés dans la garnison la russie qui
a d'ailleurs montré diffusé des images
de blindés ce soit un manuel macro et
joe biden disent vouloir vérifier
l'annoncé d'un début du retrait russe
autour des frontières de l'ukraine vous
le général le militaire comment ça se
passe ça ne suffit pas de montrer ces
images il faut vérifier pourquoi cette
demande américaine et française mais il
faut vérifier le retrait du dispositif
effectivement ce n'est pas parce qu'on
embarque quelques chars sur des trains
que le dispositif en lui-même pas on
parle si vous voulez du on passe du
discours au fait pour reprendre ce qui
vient d'être dit c'est à dire que avance
s'était nous n'attaquerons pas nous
n'attaquerons pas nous n'attaquerons pas
maintenant c'est l'effet effectivement
le départ on arrive enfin et les les
anglo saxons les américains et
britanniques en particulier ont pas
encore complètement réalisée à la fin de
la période de tension des deux côtés
c'est à dire que la mobilisation qui
avait du côté russe a mené la tension et
de l'autre côté le discours américain a
mené la tension le but du président
poutine pardon était essentiellement
qu'on prenne en compte les nouvelles
structures de sécurité qu'ils souhaitent
voir met en place vraiment bien sûr
changer ça n'a pas changé mais donc j'ai
mis la pression pour qu'enfin on regarde
ce problème de sécurité de l'autre côté
l'appel de tension qui monte vous citiez
les rats que j'étais à new york en 2003
dont je me souviens très bien cette
espèce d'emballement pour faire monter
les choses qui a deux effets
le premier c'est que tous les européens
se sont regroupés sous les ailes de
l'otan maintenant quand dans une semaine
on va voir que la russie n'a pas attaqué
est ce que les européens vont réaliser
enfin qu'on leur a raconté des
balivernes que les américains ont
raconté des choses qui n'étaient pas
vraies et que donc il faut se méfier de
ça et le deuxième point dont on parle
pas beaucoup mais quand même important
c'est le sujet économique l'économie
ukrainienne on a pris un sacré coup les
bourses se sont effondrées un peu
partout il ya des gens qui disent faire
beaucoup d'argent sur cette crise et ça
il faut pas l'oublier et puis la sphère
du pétrole bien sûr le pétrole est à 100
$ au jeu mais voilà donc il faut prendre
en compte tous ces éléments là alors
dans la ligne r de cette prudence à
l'otan évidemment année sur forcément
les etats-unis et la france a tenu un
discours de prudence également et hans
stoltenberg qui a tenu aujourd'hui une
conférence de presse on
l'écoutera
s'est jusqu'à présent nous n'avons pas
vu de désescalade sur le terrain lui de
signes d'une diminution de la présence
militaire russe aux frontières de
l'ukraine
mais nous continuerons à surveiller et à
suivre de près ce que fait la russie et
les signaux indiquant que moscou est
prête à poursuivre les efforts
diplomatiques
nous pouvons être prudemment optimistes
mais nous allons bien sûr suivre de très
près ce qui se passe sur le terrain et
si cela se traduit par une véritable
du renforcement militaire russe en
ukraine et dans les environs
mais cette déclaration du secrétaire
général de l'otan et ce soir les états
unis qui demandent à la russie une
désescalade
invérifiables et significatif anthony
blinken qui la demandaient à sergueï
lavrov xavier moreau on sent quand même
que la confiance n'est pas totalement
établi pour l'heure même si on aimait
dessiner optimiste
écouter tout ce déroule à peu près comme
nous l'avions dit sur votre votre chaîne
entre autres c'est à dire que le
psychodrame de la fausse tentative
d'invasion russe est en train de
s'étouffer puisque ni les états unis ni
la russie n'ont intérêt à un conflit en
ukraine la russie elle n'a qu'à attendre
que l'effondrement qui en plus s'est
accélérée à cause de ce psychodrame de
l'économie ukrainienne et blinken
prépare les pardons et joe biden prépare
les mid term aux moines de vente qui
s'annonce catastrophique donc finalement
les choses sont redevienne comme elle
devait être donc là évidemment on est
dans un moment de de désescalade cela
dit je me fais aucune illusion je pense
qu'en dans d'ici deux trois mois comme
en avril 2021 on va nous rejouer le même
scénario et on ira encore droit à
l'automne 2022 donc voilà ça va être
cyclique ça m cycliques pardon la seule
différence que je vois c'est d'une part
que l'économie ukrainienne est et ça ça
a été parfaitement 10 est dans un bien
pire état qu'elle ne l'était avant cette
crise d'après les chiffres que j'ai vu
ça lui a coûté 13 milliards et demi à
cause d'eux des banques run ce à quoi
auquel on a assisté et deuxièmement à
mon avis comme un facteur nouveau et
intéressant c'est le chant cieux les
choletais qui a fait une excellente
prestation contrairement à celles des
mêmes macron qui était vraiment mauvaise
c'est mon avis en tout cas c'est à dire
qu'il a parlé concrètement des accords
de minsk il n'a pas parlé de manière
évasive qu'il fallait appliquer les
accords de minsk il a parlé de que
l'ukraine devait prendre une loi qui
donne l autonomie aux dons de basse donc
ça c'est un point fondamental de
l'accord de minsk et non seulement il
l'a dit à moscou mais il l'a dit à kiev
quand il était avec céline ce qui
contrairement aux modèles mâcon qu'il en
a même pas parlé qui n'a même pas parlé
d'un simple échange de prisonniers donc
pour moi c'est les deux éléments
très favorable à la russie c'est
l'économie ukrainienne continué à
s'effondrer donc à terme ça amènera
forcément un pouvoir alors s'ils sont
libérés de prison parce que les
opposants du président qui sont en
prison ou en exil actuellement mais
s'ils sortent de prison on pourrait très
bien avoir un parent un pouvoir
pro-russe qui arrive qui arrive à kiev
dans d'ici un an d'ici d'ici 2 ans et 2
et deuxièmement donc ce point à mon avis
qui est essentiel c'est
effectivement c'est également sur votre
chaîne d'ailleurs monsieur huchon qui
est un spécialiste de la maille n'avait
dit que scholtes pourrait pourrait nous
étonner et il l'a fait ce soir en tenant
un discours assez technique sur sur les
accords de minsk et puis en faisant bien
comprendre que l'enjeu énergétique
allemand ne serait pas victime de
desmenez qui viennent ou washingtonienne
vous n'êtes pas tout à fait d'accord
c'est vrai que les allemands ont des
enjeux
et bien sûr ils ont des enjeux
économiques mais j'aurai un petit peu
contre eux ce qui a été dit le duo
franco-allemand a très bien fonctionné
souvenons nous qu'en même que le
président macron il est allé il ya une
semaine c'est à dire en plein coeur de
la crise et il a commencé par aller à
moscou avant d'aller à kiev et de parler
de l'application des accords de minsk et
pardonnez moi mais il a bien parlé des
lois qui devait être passé par kiev sur
les zones de l'est de l'ukraine et le
président le pardon le chancelier je lui
est arrivé une semaine après et a fait
le trajet inverse c'est-à-dire kiev
moscou donc c'est un duo qui a très bien
fonctionné c'est le premier point
deuxième point je voudrais revenir sur
le mot vous avez employé qui est très
important c'est la confiance je crois
que c'est ça le problème le problème
c'est d'établir de la confiance pour
avoir la confiance il faut rétablir des
mesures de transparence comme elle
existait il ya 10 ou 15 ans lorsqu'on
avait mis en place les les modalités
d'inspection à l'est comme à l'ouest de
ciel ouvert et ses acteurs qui
permettent d'établir la confiance parce
que sinon évidemment on repose sur des
images américaines d'un côté sur des
images russe de l'autre côté chacun
cantonné dans son coin
pouvant raconter des des messages
diamétralement opposées sur une même si
tu as un pot de propagande du côté
américain on aime on a vu après ça on le
sait qu'elle a fait référence régis le
sommier on nous annonce ce matin dans le
sauna que l'invasion il ya une heure du
matin non ce ne sont pas les heures du
matin mais non ce qui est oui oui en
effet juge
d'avoir votre avis de militaires là
dessus et régis le sommier vous qui
connaissez bien aussi les états unis il
ya une stratégie anglo saxon et
notamment aidé par la presse qui joue un
rôle clairement moi je suis assez
terrifié de 2,2 ce que je vous de ce que
j'ai vu là parce que on en a on en a
parlé de justement de la ddip trélut de
la guerre en irak on se souvient tous ou
même de la guerre en libye on se
souvient tous du moment où
l'intervention du point de vue de la
narration devient inéluctable ou 7 ce
souhait d'intervenir s'impose au monde
comme une solution absolue parce que que
ce soit kadhafi où saddam hussein ces
les news les nouveaux hitler il on y
voit là y est ils ont changé et il faut
absolument sauver le monde là on a eu le
même les mêmes accents on a eu à nouveau
un joe biden qui est là aussi on peut
quand même raisonnablement se poser les
questions
que quand quand c'est le daily mail ou
quand ces quelques voilà un peu excité
et c'est avec une phobies antirusses
faut bien reconnaître chevillée au corps
depuis longtemps voilà que à travers la
plume d'un journaliste d'un journaliste
où des informations de ces médias là on
peut comprendre que voilà on met ça
venait de la maison blanche aussi la
maison blanche a parlé de la date du 16
février annonçant qu'à l'aube
l'intervention allait commencer donc il
y avait chez chez by données de façon
depuis depuis un petit moment il peut se
poser des questions sur ce que fait le
président américain il a inutilement
provoqué un chaos en afghanistan en
précipitant un départ qui aurait très
bien pu ce faire beaucoup plus en ordre
en d'abord respectant ses alliés en les
informant ce départ d'afghanistan ça a
été une catastrophe
ça a été d'abord le début
de souvenez vous on s'est dit le départ
d'afghanistan même trump à réagir c'est
à dire au fond d'eux s'est débarrassé de
trump on a enfin présidence civilisé là
on l'a vu à l'oeuvre ensuite on l'a vu
humilié inutilement les français dans
l'histoire des sous-marins l'on peut
l'expliquer mais le fait de simplement
de deux se rendre compte que boris
johnson et joe biden sont un sommet
international qui va nouvelle macro est
là qu ils savent que le bientôt le
comment et ne prévienne n'est pas
emmanuel macron donc milliers
inutilement donc à chaque fois c'est
inutile et là encore une fois on fait
une surenchère sur la guerre qui est
complètement inutile puisqu'il le filet
il n'y a pas de guerre en tout cas pour
l'instant il faut le souhaiter que
s'inscrivait attaquant est ce que c'est
vous partager l'analyse de régis le
sommier ou voilà c'est une forme vous
avez pas dit - incompétence mais d'une
certaine manière vous c'était finalement
une stratégie totalement voulue et
maîtrisée par washington avec d'ailleurs
l'aide des médias anglo saxons alors
maîtrisé je ne sais pas voulu
certainement quand je dis pas maîtrisés
c'est parce qu'il ya un emballement gelé
vécu aux états unis en 2002 2003 si vous
voulez vous avez un emballement et il ya
un moment où on peut plus dire le
contraire c'est pas possible on est dans
la voix je me souviens que j'étais à la
mission française à l'époque et le
diplomate français qui négocier les
résolutions au conseil de sécurité me
disait j'étais colonel à l'époque et mon
colonel dites-moi quand ils attaquent
j'en peux plus parce que toute façon
c'est qu' il n'y a pas d'issue c'est
comme ça et donc on est dans cette
logique là c'est là où je pose la
question du résultat après alors il faut
attendre la fin des tensions d'ici une
semaine ou quinze jours mais quand on va
voir que la taxe n'a pas eu lieu le 16
alors que tout le monde jure et que ça
avait lieu le 16 qu'est ce que vont dire
les européens qui se sont fait prendre
une nouvelle fois dans le piège de
l'intoxication américaine qui avait été
la même au moment d'irak
dans laquelle ils ont été abandonnés au
moment de l'afghanistan et dans lequel
aujourd'hui se sont fait prendre alors
il faut il faut bien faut bien tempéré
les choses c'est à dire que et c'est ce
que la france vit toujours nous sommes
des alliés de l'otan mais nous sommes
vos amis et c'est pour ça qu'on peut
vous dire la vérité alors que les autres
sont pas toujours prêts à dire xavier
moreau le gênait en traquant nous a
parlé de sang froid la france d'ailleurs
il faut quand même bien le dire est
resté plus calme que les états unis dans
cette affaire notamment serait-ce que
les déplacements de l'ambassade appelé
ses citoyens ap fuir l'ukraine ce que
n'a pas fait la france c'est ce qu'a
fait les états unis je crois que la
france sonate en mi melle macron cas d
élection présidentielle dans deux mois
il a bien compris que déjà la russie
n'avait absolument pas l'intention
d'envahir d'envahir l'ukraine et que
donc dans la mesure où les choses
allaient s'arranger comme on l'a annoncé
encore une fois sur cette chaîne ya
quelques semaines il pourrait bénéficier
de l'image du du faiseur de paix dont
qu'il a il a plutôt bien joué à mon avis
plutôt du point de vue intérieure que du
point de vue des affaires
internationales et en revanche ce qu'il
ne faut pas négliger c'est l'idéologie
il y à toute une partie de
l'establishment américain de l'état
bichonne français sous le quai d'orsay
en france est tenue par les
néoconservateurs c'est pas un secret qui
attendait dans bye donne le vengeur anti
poutine qu'ils allaient faire plier
poutine et kehl ce à quoi ont ils
assisté en 2021 et bien un rapprochement
progressif de l'administration de biden
avec la russie il ya eu cette rencontre
qui a été accueillie avec horreur sur
cnn notamment par garry kasparov en
genève entre poutine et baden il ya eu
un défilé des représentants américains
burns le chef de la cia et victoriano
landes lui blinken tous ont défilé à
moscou est donc en fait vous avez tout
cet establishment qui a une grosse
influence dans les médias américains est
aussi également dans les médias français
qui qui qui enrage de voir que baye
donne n'est pas le vengeur espérer mais
finalement peut-être celui qui va
continuer le plan de trump qui était de
ménager la russie pour pouvoir se
tourner vers la chine et donc il faut
pas sous-estimer cet aspect idéologie il
y a des gens alors pour une pour nous
quatre qui sommes des gens parfaitement
rationnel et qui avons une analyse
rationnelle ça nous concerne pas mais il
ya des gens dans les médias français et
surtout dans les médias anglo saxons qui
sont qui croient absolument à cet
affrontement civilisationnel qui sont
encore dans l'est dans les délires de
brzezinski 10 10 à 30 ans voilà donc
donc il faut prendre ça en compte et ça
explique l'hystérique que vous avez noté
qui vous surprend d'ailleurs je vous
comprends en tant que personne
rationnelle que vous avez pu observer
dans les médias anglo saxons et dans une
partie des médias français
malheureusement enfin en tout cas tout
n'est pas réglé parce que moscou de son
côté 1 ne s'estime pas franchement
satisfaite puisque la dir poutine a
encore demandé aujourd'hui ces garanties
de sécurité il a répété ce qu'il a
toujours dit si on propose de l'écouter
et ligne voulons nous d'une guerre ou
pas bien sûr que non c'est pour cela
qu'on a avancé nos propositions pour un
processus de négociations
nous sommes prêts à continuer à
travailler ensemble nous sommes prêts à
nous engager sur la voie des
négociations mais tous les problèmes
comme indiqué précédemment doivent être
considéré comme un tout généralement on
parle beaucoup de la vie de l'occident
la qui parle d' apaisement mais enfin la
russie n'a toujours pas eu ces garanties
de sécurité notamment sur la fameuse
extension de de l'otan alors non mais
vous avez raison on l'extension de
l'otan je pense que ça va pas être
vraiment le sujet
du côté je connais votre avis là-dessus
c'est un sujet pour la russe oui mais je
répète que la russie a eu tort de
déposer un papier sur la table c'est pas
comme ça qu'on commence une négociation
on commence par se réunir voir les
points de vue des uns et des autres et
comment on peut bouger parce qu'il faut
arriver à un point de vue commun ceci
étant on est arrivé à un maximum de
tension ces tensions ont fait qu'on doit
venir avec des positions sur la table
dont le président poutine d'ailleurs au
passage a souligné que certaines
propositions du président macron était
intéressante et à retenir donc ce qu'il
faut c'est pas laisser retomber ça et
pas revenir comme cela était et c'est un
risque que au printemps prochain on
revienne à une autre période de tensions
il faut absolument exploiter dans la
foulée que tant que le faire est chaud
comme on dit de façon à pouvoir recréer
les mesures de confiance qui prendront
une partie de ce que la russie veut une
partie de ce que l'otan ou l'ouest veut
mais en tout état de cause qu on arrive
à une vraie négociation ce qui n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui c'est une évidence
régis au sommet de toute façon le
chancelier allemand et président du sne
au lit les négociations vont se
poursuivre là vous parlez du printemps
prochain mais enfin la sphère n'est pas
réglé à ce jour non l'affairé n'est pas
réglée puisque le pré le fin le point
principal
finalement 2-2 d'affrontements ou enfin
soulevé par les russes c'est la question
justement d'empêcher pas d'avoir des
garanties d'ailleurs c'est très
intéressant de la façon dont les dents
les russes quand on regarde au niveau du
vocabulaire quand il parle de cette
crise il parle d'un dialogue de sécurité
c'est le mot sécurité il tient qui est
important fondamentale il n'y a pas d'
ugly n'ya pas l'ukraine là dedans rennes
est un texte ce qu'a d'ailleurs cela
ressemblait c'est
l'idée la perspective d'un règlement
global je pense que c'est ce que les
russes voudrait parvenir à imposer ou en
tout cas à ce qui est l'accord tourne
autour de ça et l'idée étant pour eux
viscéralement que l'otan ne soit pas à
leurs frontières c'est quand même une
quelque chose qui peut apparaître quand
même comme légitime quand on quand on
regarde ce qui s'est passé en cas en 86
comment ronald regan pro prométhéa
gorbatchev que l'otan ne s'attendrait
pas à l'est en réalité aujourd'hui non
troupes sont déployés on le voit on le
voit bien le nom à derna une présence
française en estonie en roumanie les
américains vont proposer un contingent
de 3 3 millions en pologne ils ont
rapatrié d'ailleurs en perspective d'une
invasion supposer leur 186 militaire
d'ukraine tout simplement pourquoi parce
que l'ukraine ne fait pas partie de
l'otan donc si l'ukraine est attaqué
l'otan ne va pas en revanche ces autres
pays là dans lesquels sont disposés des
troupes ce sont des troupes qui sont là
pour dire si vous envahissez l'estonie
la roumanie ou la pologne eh bien vous
vous vous mettez dans une situation où
vous allez tuer des français des anglais
des allemands ou voilà et c'est ça
l'aspect défensif du principe de l'otan
mais là là donc la russie ce qu'elle
demande c'est justement de ne pas voir à
ses frontières l'alliance à 30
atlantique
là pour le moment on a entendu le
président alain ski dire que ça ne
serait pas le cas en revanche chez elle
son ambassadeur à londres qui a eu des
propos un peu moins un peu plus ennuyeux
et du coup qui a dû corriger ça parce
que ça c'est le problème de fond et si
ça s'est résolu on parle de
finlandisation d'ukraine et des termes
qui sont utilisés de façon à ce que
chacun puisse faire un pas et qu' on
n'arrive pas à un conflit l'idée c'est
d'arriver à ce que ces conflits
éternelle qui existe depuis 20 ans
comment dans le monde les interventions
occidentales où ces gros conflit ne se
produisent pas en ukraine l'ukraine ça
fait presque partie de l'europe on n'a
pas envie que ça devienne un champ de
bataille extrêmement rapidement parce
qu'il y avait un autre développement
aujourd'hui général train quand la
reconnaissance des territoires
séparatistes serait une agression sans
arme avertit paris ça c'est encore un
pont un autre pendu du conflit
c'est l'opposé des accords de minsk
c'est l'opposé dire qu'en 2006 le
président poutine le président macron le
chancelier 10 pour revenir à l'accord de
ministres l'accord de mines c'est quoi
c'est un statut spécial pour les régions
de l'ouest mais au sein de l'ukraine
donc pas une reconnaissance comme l'est
par exemple la transnistrie que tout le
monde a oublié sur la frontière moldave
donc c'est important de revenir à
l'accord de minsk pour maintenir les
frontières telles qu'elles sont mais
donner une plus grande liberté à cette
population russophone qui est dans l'est
de l'ukraine il faut préciser que
peuvent l'admirent poutine a dit
qu'aujourd'hui que cette reconnaissance
de l'indépendance de ces deux n'était
pas d'actualité donc voila merci merci
de préciser effectivement merci régis le
sommier merci générale 5 ans et à vous
aussi merci xavier moreau pour ce
décryptage